when i was about 12 years old i was made
to learn
ancient greek at school so
i can read the greek letters that i've
forgotten
most of the words and anyway modern
greek is completely different from
ancient greek
but looking at this periodic table i was
surprised
to find that the word for
lead which i would pronounce
molybdos is almost the same
as the word for molybdenum which i think
in greek
something like molybdenum but i probably
got them both wrong
but i never really thought why
molybdenum was called molybdenum
lots of you have commented
on our youtube videos that you find it
hard to say the name
molybdenum and it's an amazing element
neil's favorite
but why were the names almost the same
eventually i felt i should look it up
and it turns out that it's for much the
same reason
that we call a pencil like this
a lead pencil because you can write
things
and if you take a piece of lead
this is i'm at home so i don't have
samples of elements but this is some
lead from the wiring that we removed
from the house
you can write with this as well it's not
quite as good as a pencil
but you can see you can write with it
so you can imagine that when people
discovered graphite
which was mined in the north of england
in a place called borodale sadly the
mines are now all
spent but they still make pencils there
and so pencils like this are called
a lead pencil graphite itself
looks rather nice i've got an amazing
bottle
of graphite looks like an english
policeman
perhaps the hat's a bit bigger than it
should be and
if you open it and shake
out comes particles of the
graphite which you can see look quite
silvery
the thing about graphite which is
unusual as well as you can write things
is that it conducts electricity here
i've got a small piece of the
mineral molybdenite
was discovered before the metal and you
can see
it looks quite silvery and
although it's not quite as good as
graphite
you can write things with it so
it was not surprising that when people
discovered this
they thought it might be related to lead
so when this mineral was discovered
and the fact that you could write with
it
which was towards the end of the 18th
century
the people who discovered it or
characterized it needed to choose a name
and in those days people like to give
classical names and for some reason
they chose the greek word for lead
to characterize this mineral rather than
the latin word for lead which is plum
bum
we talk about in english about plum
lines and
things like that so this mineral
which was rather an obscure mineral
ended up
with the name molybdenite
then a few years later
because this is not an element this is a
mineral
people succeeded in isolating the metal
from it
and therefore it was natural to use
a name derived from the mineral to
describe the metal
and hence it got the name molybdenum
so that's why on my greek periodic table
you go from the greek name for lead
to the name for the mineral
to the name for the metal which then the
greeks
have to translate back into greek
and it comes out almost the same word as
their word for lead
now i think this stuff looks
really strange because it looks almost
like a metal and it's in fact molybdenum
sulfide
mos2 molybdenum disulphide
and graphite and molybdenum disulphide
have similar structures of layers
of in the crystal and both of them
can be used as lubricants molybdenum
disulphide is used
in car engines and graphite is used for
lubricating locks which is why i have
this
it's designed for opening locks that are
a bit rusty
did you know you can support periodic
videos and then
have your name appear here under an
element on our periodic table of patrons
you could even be our first molybdenum
or lead supporter
or if you prefer join the flammable fans
here under hydrogen
everything's available details are on
the screen and down in the video
description
thanks for watching and thanks for
supporting us
why should there be liquid but the clue
came when neil
took one of these wires to our
nanotechnology center
and there they can use electron
microscope to take images
of the angeloids or the surface of the
andeloid